hi there everybody it's Kevin Van horde
standing in for reviewer lathe Johnson
to tell you about hearthstone the name
hearthstone refers to the white and
turquoise rock that sends World of
Warcraft players back to ends but it
also suggests friendly competition far
removed from the battles and weighty
stratagems of other one-on-one
collectible card games
if world of warcraft was the every man's
online RPG then this is the every man's
collectible card game few other card
games rival heart stones charming
personality it reveals itself in the
little things such as the way you can
fiddle with watermills on the board
while you're waiting a challengers next
move you see it in the way war crafts
most exaggerated figures guide you
through a tutorial that's as helpful as
it is fun
harsh stones great strength however is
that it welcomes you with open arms even
if you've never played the genre before
what's more it avoids caustic speech by
limiting players to preset responses
hearthstone shatters barriers to entry
while supplying the means to access
greater challenges if you seek them
harsh stone adopts the familiar model of
whittling down the opposing players hit
points with attack points from cards but
it simplifies the cumbersome resource
mechanics of other games for a mana bar
that automatically expands with the
passing of each turn it's a system
geared towards speed and hero abilities
that don't depend on carts like the
mages fireball act as wild cards that
can keep players in the fight it's a
lunch breakers game and indeed the
toughest matches rarely lasts more than
15 minutes
Blizzard blesses hearthstone with
significant depth in spite of such nods
to speed there's a wide assortment of
cards with specific abilities in play
some come from the nine unlockable decks
modeled on familiar world of warcraft
classes while others come from a massive
bundle of cards that players can use
with all the decks
a player using the hunter deck might
spring a trap by unleashing three week
snake cards after an enemy attacks four
minions her opponent might then fend off
their attacks by tossing down a tanky
card with taunt thereby forcing the
snakes to attack it instead of the main
hero still further strategies await a
mage could incapacitate the taunting
card with a frost Nova thereby letting
the player blast the hero with impunity
over time perhaps inevitably the process
of leveling and building killer decks
devolves into a grind Blizzard gives you
the option to craft your own cards to
counter the grind although it's here
where the veterans enjoy a significant
advantage over rookies hearthstone
simplifies many of the necessary actions
such as destroying excess cards and
neatly arranging the available cards in
a flipbook of sort but the uninitiated
get few clues as to what to focus on and
in the worst cases a player might waste
his material on a worthless card or
accidentally disintegrate one of the
best in his deck arena mode helps quash
the tedium arenas come with an entry fee
although it's usually negligible if you
manage to complete daily quests which
have you meeting specific goals to earn
rewards the allure of arena lies in
leveling of the playing field rather
than bringing your own decks into the
battle you're only allowed to choose
from one of three classes and then you
need to build your deck by choosing one
of the random cards hearthstone throws
at you until you complete a full deck of
30 cards the outcome can still be
outrageously imbalanced some shmuck
might seem to swim in legendary cards
while the one you have never gets drawn
from the deck of course it works both
ways
the next arena match could shower you
with Legendary's like Ragnaros instead
it's too bad there's no spectator mode
or a replay option so that you can learn
from your mistake
and the daily quests take long enough to
complete that you'll sometimes want to
fork out some cash if you want to play
in the arena but such objections are
minor in hearthstone
a game so brainy and breezy the quick
matches and marathon sessions alike are
immensely rewarding
you
[Music]